you hello everybody and welcome to the
h3 podcast
the only show where the host has a
perfect
well really a more than perfect score on
wiki feet
and so i think that makes this show very
special and worth watching
it definitely affects the show and
knowing that you have a good rating
number one
on your feet i is the only show with the
number one wiki feet
and just helps yeah it just makes the
content better
i think so thank you we've got a lot to
talk about today we are avoiding
drama because it has been so much drama
i hear you guys i know what you're
saying good luck ethan
thank you keemstar thank you thank you
today we are looking
going to be exploring the pokemon card
craze ian prepared a
presentation for us which we all love we
all get very excited when ian presents
for us so
do you want to explain why your room is
turning into a jungle people are
wondering that
i i don't know it's getting out of
control
it's i found a board game and i
you know i shouldn't have played it i'm
bored oh like
are you making a jumanji i just i gotta
roll five
why does it look like you're jerking
like what are you doing with your hand
dude
okay did you do that on purpose to mess
with me or what
it looked like you were stroking it bro
i'm i'm stroking [ __ ] down here oh my
god
how dare you say that
[Music]
um do you want us to call you mowgli
i was just saying i got a roll of five
or an eight i haven't rolled it yet so
the room's gonna progressively
get worse also i'm really curious about
your green carpet because i've never
seen green carpet before can you show
that
i don't think people have seen that uh
let me yeah ian got
even put in green scraps it's great it's
a little just green
carpet oh it's actually grass yeah
it's a grass or it's a astro turf yeah
what does your girlfriend think about
all this sam sam actually called me out
because
i came home with this thing here and
she's like zebras don't
live in the [ __ ] jungle right there
they're like highland creatures right
savannah
but uh you know there are zebras i still
have my gift to give you i just wonder
if we can do it on the show somehow what
gift
for his jungle room oh right right right
it's really good
yeah well we just got to remember next
time you come over to drop something off
okay okay all right i'll remind you
well anyway ian has a presentation for
us about pokemon
cards i'm really excited in fact um
you guys are going to be super stoked to
hear we got in on the craze ourselves
and
ian was able to procure two boxes like
the original boxes
um i don't know how you did that i mean
we spent like 100 000 or something on it
wow we don't need to get in the exact
numbers but
well it's my [ __ ] money i'd like to
know how much for the segment
well i'm just trying to get people hyped
i don't want to click away i want to get
you know what i mean
i want to stay tuned so we're going to
unbox that we actually have like a whole
unboxing rig so
you know do we have gloves i don't want
to touch these things with my bare
hands we'll we'll get some uh yeah we're
going to get some gloves all right
anyway super excited um oh another thing
i don't want to forget there's a new
teddy fresh collection
on teddyfresh.com by yours truly
eelocline fashion icon legendary
designer
right here to my right this is part
hello you like that old gothic it's like
a applique
felt patch come on forget about it don't
just go to teddyfresh.com
what up and then come back here peeps
what do you think about my haircut i got
a haircut too
i feel like you finally uh
made my week doing getting a haircut
really because i always beg you to get a
haircut and then you always just
you grow it out and then you just shave
it all off but you always tell me you
don't care but now it makes it sound
like you don't like the buzzing
no i like your hair and i always feel
bad when you completely shave it off
i think the haircut looks good it just
makes me look so fat
i think the hair i wish if i could
transfer my
hair onto someone else's head more
handsome then i'd be happy with the
haircut
daddy what i mean yeah well i can tell
you it does not make you look fat but on
my face
it doesn't i don't know that i like it
but i like the hair cut itself
so props prop so shout out to her family
who cut my hair
you look very handsome thank you zach i
would expect you to say that though
okay we've so we have some free brittany
update
cool and i promised you guys i was going
to follow this story i am not going to
let this go
i am free brittany all the way leave
brittany
a lot leave her alone
but you know so people are looking into
all this like britney spears era
misogyny
and there's a video that's adjacently
related that i want to watch first of
david letterman
in 2013 interviewing lindsay lohan
which is really bizarre just gives like
kind of the same energy right
so here it is let's let's watch this and
comment this is 2013. i don't think
anybody
cared about this interview at the time
right the thing about lindsay lohan
liked britney spears she
was like just a popular media punching
bag for everybody
and um but now
looking back on those behaviors it seems
so wrong to do that it's hard to watch
because you're like wow this
is yeah like this is so obviously wrong
uh i just feel bad for her frankly but
here it is yeah
now uh aren't you supposed to aren't you
supposed to be in rehab now
do not watch anything that goes on i do
tabloid now here's one wait a second i
was looking
give me a little volume dan thank you
may 2nd
yes but how long will you be in rehab uh
three months
how many times have you been in rehab
several
and what what how will this time be
different what are they rehabbing first
of all what what is on their list
what are they going to work on when you
walk through the door
we didn't discuss this in the
pre-interview so
she's yeah they do i don't know if you
know this but on talk shows they do
pre-interviews
where they're like oh this is
interesting that's not interesting yet
so they have this whole pre-interview so
they like prepare something to talk
about so they just
could not be awkward and so
it's a little unethical first of all to
switch it up on her like this
the other thing is that
well it keeps going in on it i think
dave
dave's thing cause like listen i like
dave letterman i think his thing during
the late night show was always like
i'm gonna ask people what they
everyone's really wants to talk about
because in the news it's all about rehab
he's like oh all these questions are
dumb i just want to know about her rehab
but like obviously the way he asks is is
not that
but it'll be three months and no i think
i think
to be honest i'm i'm the happiest when
i'm working and the healthiest
and i think this is an opportunity for
me
to you know focus on what i love in life
and i don't think it's a bad thing i
think it's a blessing
do you have addiction problems what did
you say bro do you have addiction
problems
she's going to rehab don't [ __ ] wait you
can tell listen to the clapping this is
like right out of the brick
already do you have addiction problems
bro obviously like what that's what kind
of question is that yeah
look at his face too he's going like
you have addiction problems i like dave
you know
maybe it's more of a statement on the
time than anything i feel like it is
every
like it's a combination of everything it
shows what
it seems like these things were kind of
like more normal
at that time but it shows how awful it
must have been especially for
the the females this is
a bad question though do you have
addiction problems like what the [ __ ]
you
talking to you now you sound like dr
phil yeah
alcohol this is a late night show not dr
phil thomas
we've discussed this in the past who did
we really when did we decide because
when you when you go to the rehab let's
this is we have to
work here for a movie we have to what
let's stay on the positives
that she's here for a movie because
she's because when you agree to do a
film
they include in your contract that you
have to do press yeah so she's here
probably against her will to begin with
but also she if she's trying to promote
her movies messing up her career it's
like they're not going to be happy with
this
yeah it's [ __ ] up it is [ __ ] up
that side of the positive yeah all right
i have a list here of things that
you've you've endured can i run down a
few things
you can read them or not read them okay
hmm
up here i know these are the appetizers
up here
these are the main courses there's your
desserts down at the bottom
those are the jokes
are you okay now it feels like people
should be helping you do you have money
saved
therapy money that's yourself why always
in trouble
you can't make a joke of it i just want
to i just tell me
i don't i'm not joking oh you're not
doing that we're not doing that maybe
one or two no this is my show now
look she ends up crying oh she did yeah
oh she's tearing up a little bit
god bless you i love you oh
why is he waiting i'm so [ __ ] up the
way he like patronizes her at the end oh
god
bless you the little old lady
yeah oh women yeah
women's are so emotional
again like i hate to go to this card but
like
if all so many hollywood dudes are such
[ __ ] [ __ ] shows
and he doesn't get he doesn't grill them
like this
i don't think what do i know maybe he
does what am i not david letterman
expert
but i'll tell you this about brittany
the the brittany uh uh conservatorship
they gotta like streamline that word
conservatorship just for you i just feel
like
they need to streamline it a little bit
does anyone
else have a problem with the word it
just feels a little dang can you say
that
conservative oh i [ __ ] it up see
jack but my point about okay so the
britney spears thing
dude kanye west is as big a [ __ ] up as
britney spears you don't see anyone's
coming in and taking over his [ __ ]
money yeah
or martin sheen or gary or or what's the
tiger blood guy
the charlie charlie you don't see anyone
coming in taking charlie sheen's [ __ ]
estate
or gary busey's estate i don't think it
would happen to
a man i agree
kanye west is way is just as [ __ ] up
if
probably more [ __ ] up than britney
spears
ian would you like to be his conservator
no i don't want to be anybody's
conservator good for you that's the
right answer
love me daddy love me daddy zedzie
do you want to be a conservator of the
jungle
i just like trying to say the word
conservator
wait whoa whoa answer the question
do you want to conserve the jungle
conserve
preserve the jungle is forever thank you
that's ian right there ladies and
gentlemen that's the sound of ian's room
do you have white noise machines like
that you should get no that's gonna
something i'm going to add we're
actually going to put a fog machine in
here too
yeah get some milk not a fog machine
that'd be awesome we're going to put
like we're going to hang like birds from
the ceiling and put a little like amazon
echoes in there and make them all like
chirp and stuff
maybe hang some ferns from the ceiling
do you have any for actual plants in
there or ferns
not yet we're we're building it piece by
piece
until it's going to look like the tiki
room in here
interesting are you gonna be having any
open flames in there like tiki torches
or anything
i mean one one step at a time okay fair
enough let's
you know you gotta have goals right
we gotta set you up like an actual live
can to the amazon rainforest or
something instead of that
instead of that shitty youtube video
behind you
oh i really live feed yeah let's get him
in the jungle for real yeah
that's temporary we can slowly watch the
deforestation of the amazon happen
live
nothing more inspiring so there's
updates on free brittany
apparently david lehrman did another
awkward one of janice jackson that i
kind of want to watch
because she had this notorious like what
is this story do you guys remember
what's the story
her nipple came out during a super bowl
live show and justin
timberland was involved timberlake
timberlake
yeah she was doing a duet with uh
justin it was janice jack
janice jack janice jacqueline and and
johnson timber
timberland shut up such a [ __ ]
janet jackson what did i say janice you
said janice jackson yes
um and timberland
right now both names okay you want the
truth
the michael jackson's sister and the
ramen headed guy
that's how that's the real truth to them
so what happened uh dan well they just
they were doing a duet at the
at the super bowl and um there was a
at the time they said a wardrobe
malfunction
although it was debated whether or not
it was really that or
if it was planned and just because of
the backlash they decided to play it off
as a wardrobe well why would they want
to leak her nip that doesn't seem like
that well
it wasn't it was covered with a pasty it
what oh
her nipple was not exposed they just
pulled her dress a little bit
why were people mad at timberlake for
that
well because he was the one who did it
oh he he reached over
grabbed her dress and pulled it to
reveal
her breasts if you watched it though it
was clearly part of the choreography i
mean it was just it was supposed to be
like a sexy thing and
uh you know uh conservative america felt
it was
disgusting to show that on a television
project so did they escape
ramen head a little bit there it sounds
like well moreover i don't think
justin got anywhere near the backlash
that yeah
it was ramen well this hearing lies uh
the issue here with her boob coming out
joey he hasn't forgotten
wait are we able to watch that or no i
mean if it
just i mean there isn't any nipple just
well let's watch it here send me the
link i will watch it off
okay all right off the screen there
but let's watch this interview let's run
through this now
tell us exactly why people are mad at
her for [ __ ]
like it's not it's not her fault she's
weird let's see let's see what layer
mask to say about it
happened from the time you got up on
super bowl sunday
to the time the the episode took place
during the halftime
i i don't want to relive any of that
you don't mind if i ask you some
questions about it
first of all you you know
that's dave he's like i got you're here
we're going to talk about this this is
what everyone wants to know that's
annoying
you didn't know it was going to happen
no i didn't you didn't know what was
going to happen no i didn't
it came as a complete surprise to you
garth is interested garth why are you
interested in this particular
conversation
i like that whoa garth brooks ladies and
gentlemen garth brooks
was not a stunt it was not premeditated
no it was nothing that you would
rehearse
no yeah so so how how did it happen what
what exactly transpired dave you're
gonna make me relive
this i i want to put all that behind me
well
well not me
[Applause]
stop
[Applause]
just indulge me situation they look so
uncomfortable
but the audience is kind of like
encouraging it you know what i mean it's
like i'm giving the people what they
want well it's like
she in both cases both of them are just
kind of like trying to
still stay kind of positive and laugh it
off but they're clearly uncomfortable
it's live right so what are you gonna do
you know what i mean
so they're trying to be like but the
thing is if they are like you know what
i didn't agree with this
i'm gonna leave then it's like there's
such thing in the media yeah they're
crazy
storms out
we'll do it live you guys should try to
find if david letterman's ever done this
to a dude
i'm curious um
i mean yeah i'll look i'm pretty sure he
has
okay there you go well just because
david leverman is kind of a dick like
that's kind of his thing right
sure you know i don't know what i've
never watched those shows so i don't
know what's his
people liked him for being a dick i mean
that was kind of part of his thing
exactly but painless as possible
uh so it truly was a wardrobe
malfunction it was just a mistake is
can we talk about something else please
i've had a day of interviews and
i'm sure you guys are sick of hearing
about it i know i am
[Applause]
i'm not so sure they are sick of hearing
about it
you guys are [ __ ] vultures bro this
whole thing is like a hyena
here's the way i look at life
sometimes things are good sometimes
things are bad
and when things are bad it's always
important to have someone to blame
so just a nip bro it was covered i don't
know that's why i believe that it's this
uh
timberlake guy
timber timberland i think where god i
thought his name was timberland
really my whole life no my whole life
timberland you're making
justin timberlake no way you're
confusing him with
i know i'm wrong now i'm looking at it
i'm just saying
i don't care about justin timberlake or
his [ __ ] roman head
do you want to show your reference to
the roman head in case people don't know
everybody knows what i'm talking about
right
justin really justin timberlake i know
what you cause
you showed me here but i think we should
show this is like how do you outlive
this bro
he literally his haircut was [ __ ]
ramen
he had literally top ramen hair
like how do you outlive that
how do you recover from that look at
this
i feel like i could do i feel like i
could achieve ramen here
like i feel like i have the right hair
for it possibly
you think i do you think my hair's
curling off
yeah it's like what you have right now
but in yellow if it was just bleached
no look at this one that's straight up
top ramen my dudes
i'm sorry this guy is not cool
he looks like on his bar mitzvah day he
got all dressed up but it's like you're
not a man
you're just 13. i know they said you're
a man but you're still only
a kid you're 13 years old
would you do you like justin uh yolo
i was never really into the boy band
stuff
yeah boy would you [ __ ] him
no no you're not mine being nice
not that i care
whoa yeah so that's why i call him roman
hood
this is this is evil's guy right here
okay wait how about this
jack jack have you seen jack nicholson
young
did you [ __ ] him oh he doesn't actually
look that hand
maybe he's kind of old already though
he's sexy
he doesn't look that good does he
hold on let me find you a really good
harrison ford young i'd [ __ ]
harrison ford young was like
yeah i'd [ __ ] him here look at this
yeah that's a cool guy i feel like jack
nicholson is kind of cool too
i remember being more handsome jack
nicholson
young but he didn't look that good in
that photo problem is he's always been
old i feel like
you don't need to be that perfect
looking but you can have
he's got swag cool factor yeah of course
he's got swag come on
daddy here you want to see jack
nicholson's swag
daddy have you seen jack nicholson
eating a burger here now that's swag
no stop it that's swag
what do you mean stop it no love me
daddy that's not a real photo
yes it is look at him that's swag bro
god damn it what's got what are you what
are you excited
i'm upset at fast food look what it does
he's at a bar he's at a ball game
he's watching a basketball game
you see what he's eating that's the
devil
yeah you're right if there's a devil on
earth it's in it's in between two
[ __ ] hamburger buns
[Laughter]
it ain't the demons on the tubes it's in
the happy meal yeah for sure it is
i'm gonna agree with you there
i love that photo of him no i don't
apparently there's like
people just apparently he just gets down
front people just documenting it it's
awesome
but it doesn't look like that today did
you lose all that
no i think he's just he's just loving
life in his old age
i don't think so bro look at this guy i
felt like i saw him
it's your boy jack nicholson remember me
is that his son
uh i don't know maybe
he's such a badass i mean he's so old
he's like the coolest dude ever yeah
god he still got the tinted glasses and
everything
that's awesome who is it now oh yeah
let's go let's
go jack dude they're getting the worst
photos of him at this ball game
this needs to be deleted so he's front
court and his stomach is hanging out the
bottom of his shirt
no that's not him it's a devil daddy
dude he's like 80. what do you why are
you giving him a hard time
what's his current photos you really
fighting me on this
he's like 80 years old
what's his age anybody here i was
thinking more like that
see that's he's younger than those it
looks old here
no he's older here bro damn
you just can't give up on jack you still
want to [ __ ] him so bad
look look here's your boy just let it
happen
either i don't wanna he's just an old
man he's living in his life
can you show the picture i sent you a
discord yeah yeah yeah oh
how old is he can somebody tell me he's
83
thank you that's really old
this is like probably 65. you know what
i mean
got it why's he always gotta have orange
tint like is that just how he wants to
see the world
you think he's still funks yeah he could
yeah you know you think so oh dude would
you
still [ __ ] probably i mean look at
zach zach would
go for it you think exactly he probably
had so many like
girls that would just die for him even
today
yeah i mean he's pretty cool today even
i remember i remember he was in a
rom-com that i saw that i liked
when he was like [ __ ] 70 and
he was in a rom-com it was about old
people dating though so
or well he was he kept [ __ ] all these
young girls and then he fell in love
with one of the moms
that was the plot oh as good as it gets
i think
yeah it's good that's a good movie i
like that movie
you know okay here's here's my pick for
do that [ __ ] um i think we already
talked about paul newman yeah
yeah we've talked about it paul newman
young is the most handsome guy
no look at this is he in um
he's in the west world right or am i
getting it paul newman no
jack nicholson no so what are you
talking about
i'm thinking of anthony hopkins oh
anthony hopkins okay i don't think he
was ever handsome but he's always been
anthony okay he's on tick tock bro he's
doing dances on tick tock yeah he's got
a pop and tick tock account
i swear to god i'll show it to you
anthony hopkins young oh man
yeah he was never like a honk but he's
kind of a cool
old guy yeah for sure i feel like he's
here you all want to see anthony hopkins
tick tock i swear to god
daddy zeddy
it's poppin anthony hopkins tick tock
here let me find some of the original
[ __ ] this one has a million views let's
see what is this
hello everyone good morning welcome new
york
it's been a tough year full of grief and
sadness well you can't do a white crayon
but 45 years ago today no i wanted i had
a wake-up call
i was heading for disaster now drinking
myself boring
okay well that's not no he does dancing
videos dude
i liked it on discord oh you sent me a
dancing one
here's one with three million what is
this
thought sila that's kind of funny
he's still got it folks
[Laughter]
two million
hey just had a thought
[Music]
these coming days are going to be the
best of days
boring
chicken in his eye no you're [ __ ] a
hannibal actor what
chick oh chicken in his eye
it's just a photo it's just a photo with
no
sound anthony what the [ __ ] i have no
problem with him being boring i think
that's great
no i gotta show you the dancing vids
yeah but i like scrolling here it is
five million views
yeah hit that slide boy ooh ooh
how old is he i mean he's still got it
he kind of seems like a fun dad you know
yeah i looked at him
[Music]
is he painting yeah i think he is
painting
cool
daddy i love anthony see i'm jealous of
that
uh kind of like if i could be that cool
when i'm old
that's so amazing
i feel like i've never known like cool
old people this is you
yeah that's my fear
that's the wrong way
look the thing is look how happy we
pledge right here the both of us do not
be that
look how happy he is i don't care not be
like
one look how unhappy i am looking at it
i pledge nothing when i'm old i'm just
gonna take a bunch of heroin and die
stop it
i agree with you about the paul newman
yeah he's the hottest right
i have a poster of paul newman oh that's
kind of good but i mean
nothing wrong with that but you have a
poster of young paul newman in your room
uh it's from when he was 50 and he's
sitting in a car
and you can see his rolex oh
you ever beat off to it jesus no no no
but his rolex sold it's the highest
selling watch ever sold
how much 16 million what holy [ __ ]
paul newman that's swag right there can
we see a picture of it oh my god is it a
special
rolex or is it what it looks like it's a
60s rolex daytona
6263 model and we'll never just know the
model
answer the question dude is it a special
rolex or is it just
special because it's paul newman's well
it was special because it's paul
newman's
and he put on the back he engraved drive
safe
me and because he used to race cars
and he was just like this badass
[ __ ] paul newman
young versus okay who would you [ __ ]
paul newman young
i feel like we've had this exact
conversation paul newman young
are you want to see him shirtless or not
dude was a stud
there's a good photo of him so paul
newman young
get out of my life facebook forever
stupid
or yeah marlon
marlon brando young and i got news
for you that means you're gay hey come
on i'm just
thought experimenting why you got to be
such a
i think newman i think brando oh really
you think brando's more handsome i'm
gonna contest that
really it's got too much forehead or
something
if you look how they age paul newman
aged better than brandon oh
come on marlon aged like jack nicholson
like 30 years before he did did marlon
brando
brandon wait brandon old this is really
what our content
is dude him old just look at this
let's that's my boy right there
that depresses me look at this now is
that a god or what
bro i would not date a man
yeah oh you can see his gut spilling out
the bottom
beautiful icon oh he looked good and
godfather though don't even hate on that
right
you come to me you come to my house
that's his son that's his son
i'm just saying that he got he was like
the most handsome man alive like it's
obviously click stop
skip the generation just turning into a
main
meaning segment what is he what are
these people are like dead
what are we doing we're being made
[Music]
and you come to my house and you call me
fat
you come here no no
you come to my house no and you tell me
i don't like this conversation this
is not for you well it is our house it's
not europe and i ask you this would you
rather [ __ ]
[Music]
marlon brandon or brendo
it said marlon brandon that google
corrected me
i thought i always thought it was marlon
brando and google [ __ ]
wrote brandon so what the [ __ ] it says
right below it did you mean brando
no let me go back let me go back because
i swear to god it did that that's
impossible
i swear to [ __ ] it did that and you come
to my house
it's our house you come into my space
and you tell me
we can have this conversation yeah would
you rather
it's my show too and i can't tell you
what paul newman
or marlon brandon stop or just in
timberlands
ramen head
would you rather [ __ ] sting he's here
for some reason
sting is my idol man
why you have too many idols you have way
too many idols dude
you gotta
you can't have like 20 idols you know my
two idols if i had to narrow it down
yes sting and dave girl
stop no that's like do you you've been
talking on the show about all your idols
for too long for you to come at me and
say
sting yeah one that you've never
mentioned police
is like stop talking i don't believe
your favorite stink is not your idol
no i i stinks on you know every police
song
you need quiz me i don't i'm not gonna
quiz you
and then you st i'm just telling you
right now sting is not your idol i
forbid it
he is he's not all right let's move on
nobody cares all right
oh we're watching this i totally forgot
we don't have an ad today so who cares
you're coming to my house
and you tell me sting is your idol
[Music]
i thought i was your idol the papa
father am i not your idol zack
am i not your idol everything i've done
for you
you are one of my idols is that one one
of a billion
zack answer immediately what's sting's
real name gordon sumner
damn it nice try dan
yeah i thought maybe i'd get him on that
so just to sum up that
whole segment i just want to say anthony
hopkins in west world
that's my goal you want to be
in west world yeah his logan west world
okay that's what we got out of here
i'm going for jack nicholson courtside
i'm already sad because i know it's not
gonna happen
you'll look good in old age i'll do i'll
be like jack nelson's in a court side
no no it's just not fair like i already
can't control my weight like what am i
gonna do when i'm 80. do you know what i
mean
there's no [ __ ] hope for me to do it
now
i am going to die no you're not
jack nicholson by quartzite you're a fat
fat
fatty no it's just not
you're already doing it you're losing
weight already you see what i had for
what i have for breakfast
i'm on this nutribull this nutra torture
nutrition should be put out of business
i'm just saying what they're doing
i did i cut oh yeah nutrisystem [ __ ] is
a criminal enterprise and they should be
put out of business you can't put
someone 1000 calories
you're looking good though no i'm not
i'm still bad
you are losing weight bro it's been like
months to be like i'll be good on the
peloton
i'm making on the treadmill i'm gonna
get all the [ __ ] jetty craig [ __ ] you
jenny craig you [ __ ]
takes time just mad i didn't do jenny
craig but i wasn't
doing it it takes time how much time
does it take elo
i mean how long did it take it to gain
all the weight years a lot of times
right
so what did i have for breakfast it was
what did i have
oh oh my god dude it was a bag of
granola i used theodore's bowl
and it didn't even it filled up like
maybe an eighth of theodore's bowl they
go
and then on the back they have the balls
to say pour it in a bowl with a
fourth cup of milk and enjoy it's like
[ __ ] i am not going to enjoy this and
how dare you even write that just say
and just i
really don't think it's a good idea no
try [ __ ]
it should be outlawed you can't tell
someone to put on a thousand calories a
day it's just not okay maybe it's not
approved by anything
i assume it is that's why they get away
with that i go these [ __ ] know
what they're doing
you're talking about how it should be
illegal how it's dangerous
like why are you doing it it sounds like
you're so did you talk about how they
tell you not to exercise
yeah they tell you the first week when
you're on a thousand calories they say
minimize your physical
physical activity you believe that [ __ ]
because you're on so little calories
they so they go
try not to move shouldn't that be such a
minimize your steps they say
like what the [ __ ] that's gonna be so
bad like
the other thing is like i hate access
did you understand like
of all the things like there's certain
things that i can do there's certain
things that i
don't like doing like for example i
don't like doing the dishes
and so or i don't like doing laundry but
there's certain chores that i don't mind
doing exercising is the thing that i
hate the most
in life it's misery do you understand
it's
misery that's how you were enjoying it
when you were
yeah i was i was trying but i do
okay i don't like it i just
where are these people that like running
like [ __ ] you well those people are sick
i love
it feels good yeah zach you don't run
anywhere
stop yes i do where do you run to
[ __ ] i run my neighborhood
really how often uh three times a week
what how long does your run last um
half hour how long you been doing it uh
since i initially dropped the weight so
a couple years
oh my god wait why don't you
get some of zach's knowledge on how did
he look zach just tells me to like eat
butter he's like telling me to do the
keto [ __ ] i was like
if you want to see results you got to
cut out carbs for a week trust me
trust me that's true and just do
everything normal
yeah just no carbs no sugar that's true
what does no sugar mean does that mean
no fruit and [ __ ] like how drastic are
we talking about
try and avoid fruit whenever i tried to
gain weight i
gotta eat carbs like if you cut that
you're really
eating so i can eat everything i want
just not
bread or fruit or or anything
yes anything with carbohydrates which is
sugar but doesn't that just end up with
you like eating like bacon with butter
and
turds and a [ __ ] thing doesn't have
to do that's a choice
yeah like just chicken and vegetable i
know it sounds bland and [ __ ] but it
believe me it works i guarantee you will
see results in a week
you did try this once before though like
this isn't a novel thing
i remember you did the keto thing a
couple years ago i don't think i really
committed
what you said you did i don't remember i
know i did but i don't remember what i
did
that's it you just cut out carbs i just
i don't buy it i don't buy it
no bread no um sugar
pasta or anything you don't even like
that stuff so
i mean bread you do i love bread or if
you have to limit it one bread a day
to help you [ __ ] because i know like
it's a lot but i feel like you
really want to see quick results i think
your problem right now is you're not
seeing results
so maybe also i'm afraid i'm afraid to
weigh myself to be honest with you
i haven't weighed myself in a long time
because i think
once i get on that scale and see that i
didn't actually lose any weight i'm just
gonna like get so discouraged and be
like [ __ ]
this i'm going straight to taco bell
don't weigh yourself exactly don't weigh
yourself don't weigh yourself
because it's disgraceful
dude i swear to god in the future
someday they can have like nanobots that
you eat
or like nanoparticles or whatever and
they will regulate your metabolism you
can eat whatever the [ __ ] you want
and then your metabolism will take
exactly what you need and discard the
rest
amazing it will happen and in our future
within 100 years
people will not be fat we'll we'll
discard every extra
or too skinny like you can just eat
exactly what you need
well you have to eat enough calories
still it doesn't create calories
so you're still gonna have to eat
unfortunately there's no solution to
that hilo
freak he was thinking oh my god i don't
think yeah i thought
i thought you were solving my problem
here
the problem is like i get so much
pleasure from eating you know
too it's like the only thing i have in
life do you understand it's like all i
have
i really have this feeling like you need
to talk to a therapist
it's like it's like more than anything
it's in the head
like psychological
exactly because of what you just said
oh yeah your parents don't love you so
you replace their love with food
how's that going to help me no
you know how's that going to help me ewa
they'd be like oh your parents didn't
spend any time with you and you were
just happy when they brought you home
fast food
because the only time you actually got
they did something for you
and so you think about that and you eat
trash
how's that gonna help me ela you want me
to revisit that trauma you think that's
going to help me
do you think that the only time i can
fulfill my soul and feel like i
matter at all is when i eat fast food
you want me to think on that
[Music]
um
sometimes i cry when i eat fast food
because no i'm kidding
[Laughter]
[Music]
i just want to say that i don't
necessarily
support you doing the nutri system
nobody does
it's bad for you it's stupid it's
horrible
it's not it doesn't make sense i can't
eat a thousand calories a day you dumb
[ __ ]
and also like they it's also like kind
of demeaning
how they do the the diet because they go
okay
fatty here's like here's a chocolate
chip cookie because i know your fat
[ __ ] ass wants it so they feed you
like unhealthy food be like look see you
can still eat whatever you want it's
like i don't want that
yeah they go here's the smallest little
muffin
but stay right here i'm gonna go get i'm
gonna show you stay here
i feel bad have you tried any of it ela
no looks like [ __ ]
my cousin i was just curious before it
was horrible
when i tried it it doesn't and the whole
thing looks so depressing
yeah in the comments of the last episode
where he said that
there was tons of people saying please
don't do that that's so unhealthy for
you
somebody should not be eating like that
and he's talking about how it is here's
your breakfast and it's like this tiny
thing with cereal
like super plain cereal and then um
i don't know he has like meal options
like pizza and it's like this
tiny thing it's really thin it's like
how is that gonna do anything i don't
know
and also what's the end goal if you lose
a bunch of weight how is he supposed to
maintain anything afterwards like
it's not actually it's like educational
yeah it's just regulated
not practical it's not practical at all
[Music]
how did you manage after you lost weight
to maintain
well i i admit i'm somewhat of a yo-yoer
um so you just gotta monitor it
you know the you know working out yeah
no one
working on [ __ ] sucks but sometimes
you gotta do it
but you know you just watch what you eat
i stick if i if i'm gonna have a bread
one bread a day you know i'll cheat like
yeah
but it's just watching what you eat
that's what it comes down to it's like
yeah you know splurging is fun
and you know you feel bad after it but
it it just you just gotta monitor what
you eat
and i truly feel keto work i swear by it
okay here we go look at this [ __ ]
okay you want to see my meals here these
are all meals okay
here i haven't had this one yet you go
oh a honey wheat bagel i can eat
whatever i want
on on nutrisystem this is breakfast
this is breakfast this is a meal okay
let's see how big it is
seems reasonable this seems reason this
is a meal dan what the [ __ ]
this is reasonable cookie i mean i was
expecting it look like
tiny i mean it's like that's not the
worst one
because breakfast breakfast doesn't need
to be that huge okay yeah i've been
eating a bagel for breakfast
that's the problem okay calm down you
guys here's dinner ready
thick crust pizza you go oh yeah now
we're talking
[Applause]
okay well that's just false advertising
that's not false advertising
yeah no that's not the crust it's so
thin that's a dinner bro
does it balloon up when you cook it it
is fraud
no this is it bruh how can they call
that thick crushed pizza
yeah that's not thick they're like we
make thinner you want to see breakfast
how about this for breakfast
look oh bowl cereal
this that's like one bite of cereal that
looks nice
eat it then [ __ ] that's just sad
looking dude it's so sad
that's my problem it looks so sad
yeah this is a breakfast muffin this one
seems kind of legit actually
oh that but that that's breakfast
the chocolate muffin
[Music]
this is what i had this morning you want
to see granola
look on the back it says
it says add a half cup of fat-free milk
and enjoy
[Music]
enjoy here
this is the whole path you can fit in my
hand
enjoy
i think i'm out i don't think this is
sustainable and also it does not teach
you
how to maintain afterwards like what are
you going to do after
eat pizza and freak out how about
companion attack
i'm not going to hate on this muffin
actually okay well we're actually
recording here and i'm not going to stay
here and let you chew
like you do in frenemies
i get anxiety when i hear chilling
sounds
you don't like asmr
tricia likes that she encouraged me to
chew on the mic
anyway we were watching this dave
letterman interview
said no no i had nothing to do with this
it was not not my deal i hadn't
i didn't know what was going on that's
that's what i heard now did he know what
was going on
no it wasn't supposed to happen the way
that it did
but you know it it looked like it was
supposed to happen that way
oh it was supposed to happen this is
part of what justin uh
apologize for by the way well by the way
they cleared it with somebody like why
are people blaming them i mean somebody
put this together it's a super bowl like
there's some
someone green lit this i was i was
reading up about it again
i mean this was so long ago that a lot
of the details were hazy for me i i
guess
what seems to be the consensus now in
retrospect
is that justin and her planned it
themselves oh they did it all secret yes
and then they got all these back
corrupting and so they denied it
but yeah i mean that's what you could
kind of tell when dave right there was
saying justin so he's saying he had
nothing to do with this or whatever
you can kind of see on her face it's
like kind of [ __ ] because um
she knows that he totally did
interesting can i play this do you think
well you can just
i watch it i mean you know i just want
to know what we're talking about
they're gonna rate it so whatever
yourself
[Music]
i'm gonna cut the sound what are they
gonna just what's right now
was weird it was definitely oh it's
definitely planned
you can't just like tear off her outfit
yeah
i don't people don't plan for that an
alf top malfunction
i think you got to build it that way
the lyrics also say i'm going to have
you naked by the end of this song
and then he does it so i think like the
senate put together like a 200 page
like report like benghazi or the 911
commission they did like that on janet
jackson's
teddy janice jackson sorry
okay so now we know that it was
obviously not a mistake
i mean how do you you can't just tear
off a whole piece over floating
like also so but why did justin
apologize to her
he did he apologized to her but i don't
know why she got [ __ ] she didn't do
anything he cried he ripped her titty
well they planned it together they
should both get [ __ ] for it together
i just don't see it i think that was the
thing is is at the time
for whatever reason she got
way more backlash than he did yeah and
that's weird like justin
is skirting always skirting out of
controversy i mean he did the action
mm-hmm by the way it's not that it's
just
maybe the times change i don't know but
like it's not even her bare breast
it's covered it is it's definitely a
times change kind of thing because i
agree now by today's standards this is
like nothing
but i guess during the super bowl you've
got like 100 million people and kids and
all these christians who are like
the devil's in the titty and they they
did they got um
they got fined by the fcc but for a ton
of money for this for
oh really can you tell me how much i
think it was like
i mean in the scheme of the super bowl
it wasn't a lot i think it was like half
a million dollars or something but
i think at the time it was the largest
um fine that had ever been issued
for indecent dude our country is such a
[ __ ] where this is like a big
scandal
i mean really i mean they have nudity
all over
tv and europe and stuff exactly i
remember when i went to germany
there was like titties on the tv i was
like what the [ __ ]
there was like hardcore porn at night
they were very conservative
i was like it's titties
it is you know
550 thousand no it's not a big deal
it was uh 325 000 actually so less than
that even
so anyway yadda yadda it's just
alone
[Music]
man this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show of an
episode
i didn't even know why we're here i
don't know i forgot okay so anyway we
were talking about free britney
right so yeah justin made an apology
okay yeah justin timberla justin
timberlake
apologized to uh brittany
he said to janet in the same apology
janet i was like oh okay that's what
you're talking about yeah and that's why
i was asking why did
it's like bro a little [ __ ] late to
apologize to janet
like holy [ __ ] bruh so here's his post
um god i'd love to read the comments did
he
has he been erasing comments i wonder
it took you 17 years for this that's the
top comment
yeah it's like a little late for janet
i've seen the messages tags comments and
concerns and i want to respond
i am deeply sorry for the times in my
life where my actions contributed to the
problem where i spoke out of turn
or did not speak up for what was right i
understand that i fell short in these
moments and in many others and benefited
from a system that condones
benefited from a system that condones oh
like i see misogyny and racism i
specifically want to apologize to
britney spears and janet jackson both
individually
because i care for and respect these
women and i know i failed
i also feel compelled to respond in part
because everyone involved
deserves better and most importantly
because this is a larger conversation
that i wholeheartedly want to be a part
of
the industry is flawed it sets men
especially white men
up for success it's designed this way as
a man in a privileged position i have to
be vocal about this because of my
ignorance
i didn't recognize it for all that it
was while it was happening in my own
life
but i did not want to ever benefit from
others being pulled down again
i have never been perfect in navigating
all of this throughout my career
i know this apology is a first step and
doesn't absolve the past
i want to take accountability for my own
missteps and all of this
as well as part of a world that uplifts
and supports
i care deeply about the well-being of
the people i love and have loved i can
do better and will do better
why yeah why did he apologize to janet i
just i'm reading about it so
the it seems like for her it was super
awful and humiliating experience that
resulted
in her being banned from the super bowl
and he just kind of like went off with
no
punishment or anything it just didn't
affect him i mean that
that is so messed up because like but if
you look at
he's the one that like i think that's
why he's saying
i think and it's i don't think he's
apologizing specifically for the action
of doing it he's apologizing for not
for not standing up yeah her basically
she got the
just being like yo i was part of this
too okay but let's
let's assume that what they said was
true that it wasn't meant to go down
like that so
basically what they're saying is yeah i
just i just
essayed her he went and grabbed her boob
and pulled her top off like
i'm sorry and somehow well they again
and i know
watching it it's like absurd but at the
time they were just playing it off that
it was uh
that it was a mistake oh no i was go i
was just going to tap her
shoulder and say good work keep in mind
too coming out this was like
free uh video sharing sites i don't
think youtube existed at the time
it wasn't being rebroadcast oh for real
yeah so
it's kind of a different time they were
able to sort of memory hole it because
people just
saw it live and that was it
so a lot of people i don't know if you
guys know this but a lot of people
attribute the creation of youtube to
this event
because the creator of youtube was
looking for this video and he couldn't
find it anywhere in line
that that titty moment changed the whole
world
and that you can even say that titty
moment gave me a job in the future
that's titties that janet jackson's
titty
gave me a [ __ ] purpose in life
in a weird indirect way i'm working now
you guys are watching this podcast
because of janet's tit
it's awesome titties
well um is that true that's really true
huh
yeah i sent an article the owner of
the founder of youtube is a little bit
of a perv or what
he just wanted to find her tit online
and he couldn't well
not perv maybe like just out of like
well he's like why can't i find this tit
and now here i am talking about on
youtube like 20 years later
wow man
it seems like it really affected her
career at that moment
like it was a really bad moment for her
that's yeah i mean that's horrible yeah
and he did britney really dirty dude he
did a really dirty
so anyway there's updates on the actual
free brittany case which i will share
with you guys here today
good news for britain alone i agree
a judge decided to he's all of us now
isn't that so ironic
yeah we laughed but now we're all
together on this a judge decided to deny
britney spears father increased power
over affairs
a rare move that could indicate
diminishing faith in james
spears fitness for the role experts say
it appears the court lacks some
confidence in the father
there must be some level of conflict and
some level of confidence in the father's
financial decision-making clearly
there's a conflict like what are you
[ __ ]
psychic i mean they've been saying it
from the very beginning she's like
please anyone but my dad
there seems to be a little conflict
the ruling was not a total victory for
brittany however the court chipping away
at the sole control that jamie has
enjoyed
over her affairs for many many years
he believes that this will not be over
for
any time soon he will he will continue
to oversee his daughter for some time
you would think it would be an idiot why
is it
he's going to continue to oversee her
for some time yeah
it's insane he should be gone dude yeah
i do not like him it's like hey we're
not sure that he's actually responsible
enough but um
can you please endure him for some time
it's like so vague don't you think it's
such a good comparison though that like
kanye
managed to keep his estate
you know the worst part for me
watching it was the part when she lost
you know um custody of her kids
yeah so sad so sad
anyway let's move on to something fun
all right ian i'm throwing it to
you so you guys are not really super
familiar with logan's
pokemon thing going on just that he's
apparently
making bank selling pokemon cards i
didn't know pokemon cards were worth so
much money
uh at all so yeah there's a little video
if you want to pull that up that kind of
summarizes it that
av put together okay what do we got here
breaking open a 200 000 box of first
edition cards so what is this like some
so this is like what does first edition
mean
it's like the first run of the cards um
so the card isn't better it's not like a
better card it's just more collectible
there's a little icon on it that says
first edition
it's only on the first run and then
every other reprint doesn't have that
okay so this is the original [ __ ]
interesting okay and boy was i wrong
for the next three hours three hundred
thousand people watched a grown-ass man
open shiny cardboard oh he's a grown-ass
man now
logan's always like hey i'm just a kid
now he's a girl in this man okay good to
know i'll remember that
wait are you strawberry a grown-ass man
okay sorry
i'm just gonna watch it i'm gonna watch
it on the planet why is this so hard to
find these boxes
the people who have or want to keep them
i cracked it open
to confirm that all the packs inside
were legit
hey what did i pay for this you paid
350k it's a lot of money for a little
box of cardboard
million dollars in the hole i still had
yet to complete the biggest transaction
of my life two boxes
at 6.75 it's done gotcha gotcha gotcha
all right all right
all right all right all right let's lock
it
[Music]
yes let's do it let's do it
i i do want to say that i am willing to
go along with this segment i am curious
but i cannot concentrate on anything
else but
but logan logan just ignoring that kovit
exists
like he's meeting people they're all
sitting in a room
celebrating just like having a party
well wait his original video that got
all these views
tell me about that ian was kind of
started this whole or did it start the
cruise but he had this huge
opening party where he bought a box for
like how much was the initial box and
then
it was 200 000. and then he apparently
pulled a charizard which was worth like
a billion dollars
his guys said it was 350 000.
uh but logic bought one a few days later
for 220.
so so that was proven to be in the words
you know wavering i suppose i'm a mother
freaking blueberry
he's a blueberry or a grown man can you
be both
anyway sorry let's see there's a point
anyway we got we've got trade cards here
to talk about
uh he bought the original box for 200
000 he may apparently made a lot of
money selling packs individually right
ian
yeah that was the whole thing he he
advertises that
initial price tag of two hundred
thousand but he auctioned off every
single pack
um for the opportunity to get whatever's
inside and i
he auctioned them for 11 000 each each
box has
36 packs in it so all in all
he made a around 390 000.
that's so interesting to me that he's
able to make mon
like if why would the people who own the
box sell the box instead of just selling
individually packed
packs if it's so valuable to you know i
mean if it's so easy to make money from
it
yeah i'm not quite sure i think this
auction off unboxing thing is kind of a
new
sort of trend so i don't know it's
interesting
i'm surprised so many people have that
much money to spend on cards
yeah so the new one he's doing i saw
paxton going for like 40
000. i was like who the [ __ ] got that
what kind of money you spend on pokemon
card [ __ ]
i'm fairly rich i wouldn't drop to 40
000 on a pokemon card
but i guess it's an investment i don't
know he kind of inflated the market
after his initial because he said that
he got it for 200 000
and then when he went to do it again he
was buying boxes for around 350 to 400
000.
yeah that's interesting he drove the
entire inflation himself
and now he's continuing to drive through
inflation
although it's it's benefiting him
because you you said like this next one
he's doing
he stands to make like three million
bucks or something
uh yeah he he now has six boxes
uh he spent two million dollars on on
six of them uh
as i said there's 36 packs per box
now they're averaging around 38 000 each
pack
wow how can you find that many people
wait how many packs is that that's six
times 36.
who is that that many people willing to
drop 40 grand on
the demographic you know like well logic
bought one so i mean
he's like a rich dude who liked pokemon
yeah but still no yeah he's doing i
think he's just doing one box
uh next week but he said he's raised
over a million for that one
and uh so if all if every pack so he's
gonna make like 70
on that if he's spent like 300 000 and
he's gonna make 700
a thousand bucks yeah if that if that
average holds
for all six boxes it would be around 8.2
million dollars
that's crazy okay listen i can't hate on
the guy
it's an interesting vertical i can't
hate on him for that there's plenty of
other things i can hate on him for
but the pokemon thing i can't hate on
him i mean maybe you're a collector what
do you think about all this
well i haven't collected since i was a
kid but i could see the pool for an
adult
yeah it's much fun i mean obviously
there's interest there's 300 000 people
watching
yeah so i highlighted the part about
mcdonald's which this whole craze has
kind of been messing up
happy meals for kids so what happened
with mcdonald's
uh it's pokemon's 25th anniversary in
like a couple weeks
so mcdonald's is gonna include little
cards
uh in the happy meals and
yeah these scalpers are going and buying
like 50 meals
like people are buying like 100 happy
meals and you know they're not eating
they're just throwing it out from the
[ __ ] car
it's like and now all these poor kids
can't get their goddamn pikachu happy
meals
crazy are these cards they're putting in
the happy meal is really valuable like
what is going on with these happy meals
i don't think they're valuable now but i
think that it's the same as i mean
neither were the
these pokemon cards in 1999 you know
what i mean let the kids have their
happy meals man
well first of all mcdonald's can you
just limit it to one
like or two per customer like why are
you selling 100 happy meals to some
teenager
come on yeah they probably should
eliminate it
i thought that was me for a second hey
dude
listen god bless i know it's your hobby
and stuff but i mean come on
i don't really give a [ __ ] that's true
logan's got people all over the country
scooping up like [ __ ]
happy meals
huh okay
well with all the hype i want to get on
i see how excited people are
logan's making like millions of dollars
so i says
i'm rich i got money laying around i
want to make money so we
bought our own first edition
pokemon packs ian
somehow was able to locate this i think
what did we spend we got two
full boxes we spent about five hundred
thou
our yeah five hundred thousand dollars
tell me about the handoff
i mean it was it was all very sort of
backdoor
you know a lot of channels i had to go
through this guy named the pokey pimp
actually the pokey pimp wow the problem
for real
damn okay so we have two boxes
so i'm really excited we actually have
this rig here i'm going to do an
unpacking and everything
so here
[Music]
right off the bat i have to tell you
that i'm a little skeptical
of whatever this is because their boxes
seemed like have hard plastic and stuff
but this is just saran wrap so maybe
they just
were extra safe well there's no plot it
doesn't
why is this saran wrap dan i mean it
looks pretty secure to me
mm-hmm it says pokemon yeah i mean legit
yeah
vr yeah i got the gloves on our top
camera
yeah uh here let me activate it one
second okay we've got the overhang
overhead camera and as you guys can see
this is us
this does not look first edition this is
saran wrap ian
you didn't ask any questions when you
saw this this doesn't look right
i i mean he looked looked trustworthy to
me this is the pokey pimp i mean
this is yeah it's interesting was he
wearing pokemon merch
was he dressed as a hatch or what or
rocky yeah
rocket team or whatever the [ __ ] yeah he
was decked out
okay okay let's see dude i think i feel
like you're not taking this seriously i
spent 250 thousand dollars on this game
you guys be gentle no it's 500 000 for
both i'm not saying
[ __ ] okay and by the way you gave me a
[ __ ] 200 250 000
pack that's wrapped in saran wrap ian
maybe this is
being extra careful okay here go ahead
to the overhead
all right extra careful what are you
talking about be very gentle and be very
gentle yeah
well
okay oh it says first edition here it
does it does say first edition so
it says one edition oh [ __ ] i ripped
them
oh my god the boxes oh my god all right
let's see the overhead
okay here we go oh my god
huh oh [ __ ] just what the [ __ ] is this
yo ian this is robin hood prince of
thieves no no no no
that can't be right there's no way was
that one of the um the generations of
pokemon
was there like a like a robin hood like
spin-off kind of thing that happened at
one point or something
i haven't followed pokemon in a while so
i don't see any mention of pokemon
this is literally robinhood prince here
show this ian what the [ __ ] is ramona
why are there robinhood prince of
thieves playing cards even
maybe open one and see if it's like
mistakenly
yo did you steal you know what's gonna
be special yeah
it could be worth more if it's a
misprint actually so
are um are robin prince of thieves cards
worth anything can anyone look those up
unboxing here see what we got
are you supposed to tear i'm not sure
how to open it
these packs are ancient okay i guess
there's a
yeah all right here we go now it's
worthless nope these corners look good
to me
we're gonna have to send these to get
raided for sure oh here we go
is that the cause this is
we got kev oh it's just the sticker it's
just a sticker
oh okay okay so that's that's that's
like a bonus that comes in there let me
put this like
here let's get the pack okay we got the
cause yeah here
so this is a sticker but here's the
playing cards okay here we go
so we've got um can you see that dan
they average from five to ten bucks on
ebay per card
i know for like a whole set for a whole
set ian
what the [ __ ] did you buy it doesn't it
cost like 10
just to get it like rated i mean that
doesn't even cover the whole set what do
you mean the whole set like every card
it says trading card set 55 cards for
five dollars oh
[ __ ] god that's the whole set bro
why am i even wearing these gloves these
gloves cost more than the whole set well
hold on let's see if we got any foils
sure what a blaze especially doing a
pandemic
sure with a blaze you still there look
at the image it's so stupid
it's just a dude on a bridge it's on f
like it doesn't make any sense how is
that a trading card
it's just a frame from the movie
it's so dumb maybe the charizard is
buried a little bit
yes oh happily ever after they're not
characters why are these like a battle
for nottingham
england at last what the [ __ ] bro
where's the goddamn
a plan is hatch they're just describing
the plot of the film
that's a good card i think that's a
worthy what's the stats how much hp does
uh
it's just like a plan is hatched nah
that's like
25 that's actually that's that's a lot
of um that's a lot of
key points we will set traps then you'll
take that to the
robin hood the restaurant you're putting
too much pressure on it you're like
gonna bend the corners
what and if you take that to robin hood
the restaurant you know how many burgers
you can get you mean ron
robin what do you mean round robin not
robin hood the restaurant gila
round robin red robin red robin red
robin
oh yeah
can i please read the card a plan is
hatched we will set traps and then hide
among
the trees and bush brush of the force
explains robin
why are you even including explains
robin just do the quote like how dumb
they they expect me to like they expect
me to like watch the movie through these
playing cards well
if you haven't watched the movie you
need that context when the share
i think they're just quoting the film
dude when the sheriff men come into
sherwood to capture us
we will surprise and catch them instead
so it's like an ambush card it's a trap
card what am i going to do with all
these packs
can we acknowledge robin hood the theme
being stealing from the rich
true i feel like you got robbed
yes somebody robbed for me and i don't
think it was robin i think it was ian
like where's the pokemon pack that i
spent 250 thousand dollars on
i mean i'm not super familiar with the
pokemon lore
after i could tell you for sure that
robin hood in
tights is not part of pokemon lore
yeah i mean okay can you show the
overhand cam please don't get me what's
going on arthur is so ugly
oh here's a character made marian
okay i got it made marian so i got a
character card that's good
this is my second sherwood ablaze
that unfortunately is that's a common
that's a comment yeah that's a cool
about make way for the beggars that's
what this one's called
here whatever that means
oh i got azeem azeem azim praised by
night
here i want to find at least one robin
hood well look at all these packs what
what is this what is this
oh you know what i just remembered i
used to have barbie cards i wonder if
those are worth a lot
no they might be i'm here for pokemon
cards
i don't care they might actually be
worth money
it's probably my mom yeah
i doubt it it's like oh barbie how many
how many options are there barbies
really sick cards i'm like this ugly
yeah these are disgusting i don't know
why
what is this design of the red and green
and like why don't they change colors
they're all the same i think i damaged
the corner all right where's robin hood
come on you [ __ ] a hero's death
who's this [ __ ] when since when was
what's his name christopher columbus
i think that might be pikachu that's not
pikachu ian
this is uh what's his name you guys know
his name what's his name uh uh
christian mewtwo oh
why is christian slater in this pokemon
pack
hatch a plan got it face of terror
oh the evil guy you got to show it
literally says the evil guy
the evil guy evil guy read it it says
the evil guy oh maybe
maybe god is an evil guy well whatever i
don't have
watch a demon die all right
look okay i mean maybe it's just a
collection of misprints which would be
very rare but we do have two boxes so
yeah
you know these aren't misprints these
are robinhood prints of thieve
packs all right let's check the other
box
yeah just check the other box here ethan
okay this doesn't look much better i'm
gonna just say that
out right now i think the packaging
looks way cleaner on this one
you think so yeah i got a good feeling
it says first edition
limited printing it's a little distorted
okay let's open it up carefully
carefully printed and stretched in
photoshop or something
that might just be because it's old
you're not distorted
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right it's
kind of falling apart too
looks legit got to catch them all go
ahead show that
[Music]
gotta catch them all
all right yeah that looks real okay this
one was 250
please don't [ __ ] me again ian
this is not pokemon
desert storm the invasion
desert storm trading cards coalition for
peace
is this something you can't tell me this
is a misprint
um hold on i gotta make some calls
can we call the bank and cancel the um
no
i gave him i mean i'm gonna have to do
something because i gave he i gave him a
check for half a million dollars
he gave to the pokemon pimp um he
already cashed it like last night i saw
the money exit our bank
he's gonna really try to tell me this is
a misprint here show me opening this
why is there desert storm trading cards
isn't that weird like glorifying war
what is this it's like what is this it's
not even a complete image
what is that is this the back oh it's
like a sticker but it's just a piece of
an image
all right guys you get get excited
you think this is rare the chinook
you guys say they look a lot more
machine gun ready this is kind of sick
like why are we
have war trading cards this is some
dystopian [ __ ] isn't it
i'm hoping for george bush senior
saddam hussein is the mewtwo saddam in a
hole
is a trap card heat storm in the gulf
what the [ __ ] who's doing what oh i did
get a player card
here we go who's that chief of staff
general charles gabriel chief of staff
can you look up if this has any value i
hope you'll find a schwarzkopf
he he was the big man is this worth
anything this is general charles gabriel
chief of staff
let me check it out on the uh on the on
the auction sites
oh scud missile in did you get a hold of
this guy cause these are not
pokemon cards this is a scud missile
uh i'm having a little trouble getting
through
pokemon
[Music]
yeah it sounds like you should just try
again no can you stop payment on a check
that's already been cash
how much is this how much is a scud
missile worth baby
uh two dollars i'm actually seeing two
dollars yeah for some reason no one has
more value
the cheapest dev f15 fighter plane whoa
is that a rare can i get some value
check on this please at 15 i mean that's
a good plane
moving in baby oh [ __ ] let's kill some
iraqis
hey can you say that i don't know that's
what it was though right they were
killing iraqis
uh that is what operation desert storm
was i mean i'm not condoning i'm just
saying
that's what moving in means they're like
let's go [ __ ]
let's go get it done moving in here i'll
read you the
caption yeah formation and carriers of
planes shown here a carrier ship with
its escort ships and planes
travel in breathtaking formation
across the ocean the planes take off for
their mission from a runway
although things appear quiet servicemen
are constantly monitoring all systems
within the ship
moving in baby damn i like the use of
breathtaking
i know these people are like such weird
military fetishes
i want to find a rock and a hole let's
see i feel like that one's going to be
worth something
i mean it's the yeah as long as you're
wearing gloves
well well hold on yeah yeah yeah that's
the wrong war but yeah
what's with the first one being a
complete random cut
uh i think here here's my one i got i
don't even know what this
is but they all come with like i guess
it's a big
maybe together an image
right okay i'm having a good feeling
about this pack
canadian air force what about
anti-aircraft chemical gear chemical
gear interesting oh chemical warfare
that's got to be worth something yeah
who's patriot control center that's good
they love their country
he's like oh is that a young coin pack
general colin powell rookie card
[Music]
this was the very early years of his war
crimin a criminality this is before he
was wanted by the world
by like uh for war crimes this is
pre-secretary of state
i'm just kidding i don't know if he's a
war criminal or not but probably oh he
definitely is
yeah that one is four dollars
four bucks oh now we're talking i'm
almost forgetting that
ian wasted 250 000.
maybe by the end this will only be out i
mean a colin powell rookie though
i mean that's pretty that's hype
is that oh that's nice
that is a dick cheney rookie that's
pre-vp
oh wow that's pre-vp of course that's
i don't know if that might be pre
halliburton secretary of defense
dude i gotta send this in for raiding
can i show you we have to get this rated
and sell it and
auction it on logan's ball show me winks
over
egypt
[Music]
it's like we could have bombed the
pyramids but we did it
we had to let them know that we could
you get it can i get a price check on
this dick cheney
dick cheney is three dollars oh [ __ ] bro
hold on
we have to send these in to get ready
look at this one you ready then
kill me wearing the gas mask
yo i've got okay we have all of our
great fun like our premium
first editions or whatever right here
we're gonna send all these in to get
rated for sure
and then like you set the value right so
i feel like if we get these rated
and put them on the auction site and the
whole like premium package and the
rating and stuff
then i feel like we could fetch a nice
are you including this one in there
no no the plan is hatched okay let's get
this one right let me check the corners
those are pretty good corners
the dick cheney card is the funniest
thing i've ever seen so wait we're gonna
do robin hood
play hash is a plan as well by accident
i looked up dick cheney rookie card
when i was searching the price for some
reason yo i've got to see if we have a
george bush senior in here because that
would
probably i mean we're kind of hot right
now like we're on a streak let's see
here
uh any of the crew auction uh
purchase a pack pre-purchase like
auctioned out park just ian you [ __ ]
i'm down half a million dollars are you
talking about purchasing you owe me
money dude
this is so random night vision goggles
it's a trap card looks great oh who's
this i'm getting duplicates
yeah who's this general richard g
graves oh that's a that's a third tier
general that's don't worry about richard
put him in the graves
let me know when you get a schwarzkopf
that's that's the that's the big boy
okay i'm actually i'm pretty i'm
rarely psyched on this do you want me to
open one of these for you guys
so it's kind of a yeah yeah i would
definitely love to get all right this
one's for you dan
sweet come on georgie okay dan come on
poppy
show the okay so we have manning the
m110
[Music]
phoenix missiles oh that's a good
missile oh
sunset in the desert sunset in the
desert that's a weird
kind of thing it's like we don't own
sunsets in there so far this pack
a little disappointing
[Applause]
so in this pack i have this one too
you got white
hold on let me read his stats oh my god
i'm so jealous man
i'm literally shaking right now
commander in chief
united states president is the
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
on january 16th he
initiated operation desert storm and was
supported by 27
other countries of nato mobilized to
protect the sovereignty of kuwait
number one you see that number one i had
a beat off
oh my god is it ready for the value yeah
give it to me yeah i'm ready
thirty dollars
[Applause]
are you serious
hold on we gotta are we gonna get send
both of these in to get rated let me
just definitely need to get those right
see this corner is not this one might be
what they're perfect what are you
talking about
this one's got a little curve in the
corner ethan please be careful
all right we're going to get them both
the verified
wow two commanders and chiefs that is
unbelievable that's unbelievable
basically back to back that's insane
that's like getting two charizards
it's i'd say it's better all right wait
where did you see these for 30 bucks
baby
uh i'm checking the same two sources but
that one was ebay an ebay seller do you
see that there's any hit does anyone
actually buying this
mission accomplished
oh that's iconic that's an iconic card
um this one's going to get certified
oh my god i got another one coming
another commander in chief
no three commanders and chief in one box
how rare could it be then and that's
unheard of
[Music]
oh another scud missile nice nice
careful
all right well we got the commanders in
chief yeah so there's really no we got
three commanders in chief
that's all right you got does anyone
want one wow dan i can't believe you
could pull the commander-in-chief
i'm calling dibs on this pack all right
this one's for zach thanks for zach
go ahead f18 flying high okay
paratrooper in flight
army supply ship
airborne unit a lot of airborne in this
pack
should there should be a picture of like
a cemetery like falling in battle
oh my god like they just i mean if
they're going to show the glory you know
what i mean
like a revive card oh yeah right injury
card
machine gunner amputee
this one is poisoning ptsd this one's
called
it shows a bunch of soldiers in a
support group
shell shock yeah marine firefighter and
then there's the one after it shows
third degree burns what about his body
um therapy nothing too good there he was
good therapy yeah sorry zach that was
a little bit of a doubt it's okay who's
this one for i mean we wanna pack
yeah i'll take it back all right well
you well finders fee
yeah okay fair enough sunset on the f-14
pretty romantic what is um admiral
frank kelso oh that's that's big that's
big i mean it's still not it's still
has not a schwarzkopf value i've not
heard of admiral frank kelso
oh that you've caliso you never heard of
kelsey
i love dan knows everything about tesla
well
he's worth three dollars oh
the control center it's kind of funny oh
interesting
yeah yeah it's a nice card yeah
all right that's it yeah all right this
one's for uab
thank you here we go you guys can never
say we didn't do anything for you guys
maybe i swear to god if you go to
schwarzkopf right now
the power of the tomahawk that's got to
be worth something
it's just a picture of it detonating
like somebody died in that
yeah that's kind of [ __ ] f-14 flies in
formation
that's the that's the top gun uh jet
that's a big deal
flying high zach got that one [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh is that is that what i think
it is
because then just said like a b i'm
gonna kill you if you get it we did not
this is
full i can't beat you dad i got i got a
poppy bush
i i i mean i should be happy but that
that
that's an iconic card that's nice we'll
talk dan we could you guys
okay wow this is exciting i mean we'll
open these later but look at all these
show all these
we're going to get all these rated we're
going to send these in and get them all
like boxed up
and if like if we can get pull some tens
on these
i think we can get some resale value on
these we got a long way to reiterate any
of
i'm going to rate the plan is hatched
you know because it's got the costs in
there
or well here this one's this one might
be good with the christian slater as the
heroes
right that's tragic nice corners
i'm kind of i feel like we got to pull a
a robin hood card
if we're going to send it in to get
ready it's kind of shocking that we have
it
there's some bad luck here i can't do it
let's pull let's let's pull a robin hood
car real fast here let's just
be careful of the corners though don't
open it too fast either because i want a
perfect 10 on these
you know are you mad splaining
i'm not mansplaining i'm just telling
you to be careful these are valuable
oh i got another i mean morgan
oh no action escape
can see hold him out a little bit more
first diet it's just descriptions oh
azim okay so i got a zim okay there's
the seam
that's kind of sick okay i'll save the
zim
there's too many just descriptions it's
like fighting on a bridge it's like okay
i want azim
now you're living hey
okay this is these ones are another azim
these robin hood men and tights ones
made marriages and that's a
that's a yeah that one's good that's
that's a decently nice corner
too yeah is there a value can i get a
value check on maid marian
i got someone show me oh yeah i already
have a hero's death okay
one dollar one dollar one dollar okay
working towards your debt ian of half a
million yeah
chip it away get in there you just need
half a million more made man
all right this is not going anywhere
these [ __ ] robin hood cards
suck ass what is this it's nothing
oh what never pulled one of those before
these are by far the worst i'm sorry
another maid marian
robin hood why you being so stingy with
me dude like you really gonna make it
that rare for me
nobody cares about your dumb [ __ ]
movie yeah i'm getting nothing
seriously what if this movie didn't even
get good rating like you're gonna make
your cards so rare
like kevin costner i'm sorry bro attack
from above
safe at last battle for nottingham
like hello i want the cost
this is outrageous oh my god do you want
to run
tomatoes 50 how much 51. that's
no that's just about it
all right i need like a little john and
i need a robin hood
oh that's true we haven't gotten a
little john yet either i've never seen a
man oh
battling little john wait it's battling
oh
that's a battle card that's not a
character card
spoils war bro i can't do that
oh i'm shaking my hands
oh my god
i am shaking right now bro
that is like perfect corners bro robin
hood
prince of thieves oh [ __ ]
careful careful five hundred dollars
no
why would you jump like that well wait
till we get a 10 rating
yeah that's that's that's unrated is the
one you're looking at certified
so you don't know what you're talking
about i'm sorry i'll buy it from you
kevin costner follows his oscar-winning
success
and dances with wolves why are you
talking about damn i'm trying i'm trying
to get in
myself and robin why are they talking
about dances plugging another better
movie
in these cards one of america's most
admired leading men costner appeared in
such hits as
water world i'm sorry or something
um wait it lists water world no
i'm trying to think of one of the
terrible movies he's
[Laughter]
wow this is exciting okay so we're gonna
get all these rated
you guys agree with this collection i
love it
yeah i mean that that's definitely the
best of the day that we've got here
what a poll that's pretty good man okay
guys so we're so i'm gonna give these i
guess dan you'll take these and get them
cinnamon to get raided
yeah um okay and and i mean i know it's
disappointing that we didn't get the
pokemon cards but i gotta say a colin
powell
a dick cheney a schwarzkopf and three
commander in chiefs so hold on wait we
got a
we got a bush a colon and a dick
i think we owe the pokey pimp an apology
we the pokey pimp
you owe me an apology for this bull i'm
trying to make the best of this
situation
but i am out half a million dollars you
get that [ __ ] [ __ ] on the phone
he also gave us another present too as a
token of uh
good business where it's behind you
oh what the hell was that he said as
a thank you for for a successful
transaction
it says pokey pack mystery box very rare
is that
is that it really look there's a pikachu
it's literally drawn with a sharpie so
it's kind of cute okay what is this joel
he biden me it's a pokemon sort of thank
you
very valuable he stressed that a lot
i think he would wrap it a little more
secure
oh what is this oh it's a pokemon oh
yeah that looks legit
is this first edition
oh wow interesting printing on this one
[Music]
tom and jerry tom and jerry trading
cards
those those are cool
those are actually uh pokemon i believe
right there i didn't know the challenge
part of the pokemon universe of course
is the overhead
here let's see let's go to the overhead
oh wait whoa whoa whoa whoa careful
careful
we're getting these rated i seriously
want these to be tens
hold on let me all right
these need to be raped good these are
important why are you so serious
dude what are you talking about these
are we need to rate these they're going
to get rated
i'm just going to get these rated and
sell them if logan could get them rated
10
touching with the pick i'm not kidding i
want to get those rated we have to get
10k
okay i want psa to give us a special
h3h3 yeah i want to get it
oh this is actually cool
no you're living i'm keeping these
oh there's no details there's just a
frame
oh where'd the stack there's some stats
on the back how much health is on this
cat yeah how much
in the hollywood bowl oh that's an
iconic episode dude oh
you can pull a holographic tom yeah can
i pull a holographic tom
i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat
is there holograms in here i didn't see
any
foils on the um oh it's got something
holy [ __ ] bro this one is oh
yo yo this one is holographic bro
it's got a little metallic thing no way
oh wait what scene is that which one
[Music]
no freaking way what does it say what
does it say
you want me to read it yeah what's this
it says william hannah studied to be a
structural engineer while joseph
barbara was in banking the two met after
being hired by mgm studio
and thus began one of the most
successful partnerships in hollywood
history
wow that's a hannah barbera origin card
yeah
bro this is okay we might have to send
this one to get rated
it's foil so whoa okay cool
i guess that makes up for being scammed
half a million dollars
wake up oh my god
all right so i'm gonna get these rated
we'll try to get like a
h3 thing and i i think we should put
them on the auction site for charity and
just like
we can we can raise money and try to
donate it you're not trying to
recoup your your losses here
well i'm going to see that guy of course
i'm going to chase him to the ends of
the time but
okay just making the best of what we've
got here
okay well ian
you're fired yeah you're definitely
fired i say we took a big win today
love me daddy all right
today is wednesday so we'll see you on
live
after dark get excited get hyped we'll
maybe here on friday live
hell yeah for a fun light
drama-free episode ah cabbage
all right now excuse me i have to go eat
like 20 nutria systems
alright guys take care tata